griff jenkins is in matamoros mexico
just across the border from brownsville
texas on what's happening
inside of a migrant camp there griff
good morning
hey bill good morning to you that's
right we're just outside that camp that
closed in that dhs
white house team came just across the
border from me we want to give you
a look though we have a drone shot that
we'll take
now this river the rio grande river is
the u.s mexico border matamoros on my
side
brownsville texas in the rio grande
valley on that side
but if you look at this camp this camp
was open for over
two years put in place when the trump
era policy
known as mpp or remain in mexico kept
asylum seekers on this side of the
border while they waited
for their claims to play out well guess
what in the last 24 hours
it has closed most all of the
inhabitants inside
this camp were allowed to cross into the
u.s
and many of them released at that bus
station we saw in
brownsville all you're looking at now is
the debris
and trash within this camp that accrued
over two years
the ngo organization doctors without
borders calling it quote
inhumane conditions for anyone to live
in many of them
families a lot of children a very
difficult
place to spend upwards of two years we
talked to some of the migrants
that were still out here that have not
been allowed to cross
one of them is a gentleman named mario
with his family here
he's from honduras he's been here about
eight months trying
to cross and he believes it's a new
administration the bite administration
will be more favorable to his cause take
a listen to what he said
the president the united states biden
held the people because it's necessary
you know
we don't have no we're staying
you know no help in the morning not
having nothing here
and as we continue to look at this drone
shot if we will of this camp
understand the process bill most of the
migrants that were in this camp have
crossed into brownsville and under the
catch
and release protocols of this new
administration we have brand new numbers
out of the city of brownsville who is
responsible for the covid testing
of these migrants that's what's new
about this crisis
it's in a pandemic not like one in 2014
or 2019 the new numbers
you can see here on the screen 185
that's up
from 108 the last update we had last
week
there and it's been 1553
migrants tested in brownsville since
january we'll have to wait and find out
if that number continues to grow but one
thing's for sure
most of the migrants that were in this
camp behind me have either crossed or
some of them
have moved to the interior what mexican
officials are a little concerned about
is whether or not the green light that
has been
perceived by many of the migrants to
come now despite the administration
telling them not to
is that they will still come from the
northern triangle from honduras
guatemala and el salvador
and at that point they're worried they
may have to open other facilities
like this there are a few migrant
shelters that are throughout the city
we're going to go a little deeper into
mexico a little later
and see what's happening at those spots
bill well actually
griff i i just wanted to ask a question
because you said something in your
report that i think is really important
you said that representatives from
doctors without borders
have described it as a humanitarian
crisis i just want to make sure i have
that right and
just have get a little bit more on that
well they've described the conditions
when this camp was open
as inhumane conditions didn't say
a crisis from what i've read of what
they said
but here's the thing because we've had
this semantic debate and i've covered
this issue
ever since i covered two caravans and
traveled all the way from san pedro
honduras
through guatemala to pierce negros a
little bit west of me
and then of course oh they went over
into eagle pass before that they went to
tijuana here's the thing though
under the obama administration we know
that jay johnson then dhs secretary said
anything over a thousand a day
is a crisis so going by his metric we
have seen
in the last seven days according to
democrat congressman henry claire
10 000 apprehensions in just the rio
grande
sector i talked to an official early
this morning
they told me that they're holding 2600
in capacity
uh in in their in their detention
centers and they only have capacity
undercovered
for 700. he told me in a text message
we can't catch and release them fast
enough
griff thank you appreciate the report